where do you think you guys will get
married oh we know there's a lot of
hidden costs in a way everywhere
we're gonna get married over here and
over there and in the sky and on a cloud
it sounds like it's gonna be a big
wedding well you know uh yeah it's it's
it's it's a conversation we're gonna
rent the moon and fill it with rosie
[Music]
the moon is infectious and exciting
today as people from all walks of life
celebrate becoming the seventh state to
legalize gay marriage
we're here talking to excited couples
about how they feel on this historic
day oh hi hi hi uh yeah it's a very
historic day for civil rights
and for gay americans and americans all
over the country we're gonna get married
[Applause]
we said that to be a conversation you
know what i mean because we didn't know
this was gonna pass
so darn fast so are you guys a couple
are we a couple come on girl let's get
serious
my name is lashon and this right here is
my
sandwich it's uh samuel yeah
and we're gonna get married
that's so great how long have you guys
been together well we've been three
years
it's been forever we've been waiting
forever it's really
important to know the person who is the
bride
i am the bride
[Applause]
well tell us all about your plans um
well you know we never thought it was
important to have a piece of paper so
there's not any plans in there
we go and get that piece of paper
centered
where do you think you guys will get
married oh we know there's a lot of
hidden costs in a way everywhere
we gonna get married over here and over
there and in the sky and on a cloud but
it sounds like it's going to be a big
wedding well you know
uh yeah it's it's it's a conference
we're going to rent the moon and fill it
with roses
we really need to talk about whether or
not we think it's fair to even get
married
when it's still illegal in so many other
states see look at him look at him
that's my man with his big hearts i'm
sorry my husband
you're my husband now well we're just my
husband now okay we just don't want to
rush into anything because stuff gets
overturned remember what happened in
california
maybe i'm gonna get a 14-karat ring the
size of 14 mother
carrots that's what's up doc
well you two certainly seem excited yeah
do we seem excited yeah
okay congratulations i hope you guys
have a wonderful life together
just we really just didn't think it was
gonna pass it's gonna be we're gonna
have a house that's shaped like a
unicorn
and we're gonna have five little girls
the name's gonna be aetna
carousel sequin abercrombie and phantom
and we're gonna have a little dog named
ruffalo
and the dog gonna have a cat named
myriad
i'm going to be honest with you samuel
adoption can be a long difficult process
we should probably uh wait for my
partner he should be here any second
baby
we having a baby we gonna raise it
and feed it and change it and dress it
up
like a pea pod hello sammy
you must be lashawn ooh you must be la
correct
okay well we were just discussing your
options for adoption
and uh how difficult it is to actually
be approved oh well you can just put us
on the list with the gold star and a
check and
a plus because we want this baby like
yesterdoodle
well as i told your husband it can be an
extremely long waiting period right
right and it's even hard
for straight couples to adopt so oh well
it's just you telling baby people that
we are going to be the best parents ever
because we're going to be strict but
also fun like for instance
everybody gonna have to clean up after
tuesday night dress up parade i
do not know what that is right oh every
day gonna have a different theme
is it so for instance monday that's
gonna be under the sea day
tuesday that's gonna be dress-up parade
wednesday gonna be based on the chinese
calendar
thursday's gonna be seeing what to do in
day
and night friday it might be very
difficult when you actually have
kids lashawn kids do you want to adopt
more than one child
absolutely absolutely totally
it can speed things up if you're willing
to adopt siblings together ah
sammy you can get a set sammy we can get
a
set not getting a set could dress them
up like companion objects
like a bat and a ball or a kite in the
wings see look sean gets carried away if
you
really want to expedite the process you
could adopt a special needs baby
yeah killing me here yes that's what we
want a special needs kid
preferably one with white eyes and can
tell the future okay so now we're
getting a special needs kid
lashawn there's a lot of extra cost when
you get a disabled child because that's
what actually special needs means to
worry about money again
how is that possible we gonna start a
family band called lashon and the sam
stations
and oh how many times can you change a
child's name
because i have this system and it's a
little bit of an out there idea but i
think if you really set up
a system where if you do something good
you get a better name
so if your name is alistair one day you
do something good your name could be
popeye
hello lashawn hello carousel oh sammy
carousel had another premonition oh what
was it this time she says an ostrich is
going to escape from the zoo today
nope she heard that on the news last
night so that's the thing that actually
happened in real life already
okay well better late than never all
right well go make daddy some chamomile
let's go
um come on go around use the fourth
there you go lashon so i just got this
letter from my insurance company it
looks like
we are officially on the same insurance
what yes
ah stanley we did it i can't believe
this
uh we're finally not gonna be treated
like second classes oh my god now i want
to see i want to see i want to see i
wanna no don't show me just tell me what
are we covered what are we covered it's
good insurance
we got dental and uh oh my god make me
an appointment right now okay
lashawn you gotta take it a ruby filling
and a fang
for apples a fang yes a single solitary
fang for tricky fruits and bottle caps
you understand that that's kind of an
elective procedure
i'm going to proceed to elect the fang
the president of my mouth okay
and then i'm going to get my voice loud
and slow
yes so i can talk to birds all right so
well i don't know if we're gonna find a
dentist who can do that also it's not
covered in this assurance because it's
the basic
dental and vision and and he's like the
general room
oh my god sammy send me something send
me something send me what send me what
sammy
that is my name i'm gonna have one
contact that looks like a cat eye and
another contact that looks like a cat's
face that's missing an eye you don't
wear contact i'm gonna have a third eye
that looks like the letter i and it's
gonna be in my eye
and i'm gonna be like i see you
lashon you don't wear contacts so
i'm going to need to wear contacts when
i have my eyebrows redid because they
say that kind of procedure will crumple
the corneas you're not getting your
eyebrows
redone undone done i'm going to have
them switched on my face so when i get
mad i look delighted
you understand that insurance is only
for real medical problems and even then
we have a deductible
i'm going to deduct the fat from my ass
and put them in my fangle so when i wave
i look like mickey mouse
okay all right listen to what i'm
telling you right now
what insurance is not for you to have
the bottom half of your body cut off
and you sew into a horse so you can
experience what it's like to be a second
target oh my god sammy
that's a good idea that's not a good
idea because you die
almost immediately it would be worth a
semi it would be so worth it sammy
please tell me i can
i know that you want to do that but you
can't don't do it
it's not covered by the insurance oh
sammy
why you got to be the 80s to my disco
right now why do you have to
i'm not sure i'm
i'm going to get another stomach one for
cherries and one for corn
oh my god that's right sammy i'm gonna
go to couples therapy alone and just
play both parts yeah i don't want to go
to the gynecologist
just ask questions till i get it oh and
i got another question a few questions
about how many different parts of your
body you can make blink because i want
to get my
ear lids done my foot pockets foot
pockets are
this invention i've been thinking of
where you can just put your keys
up by your ankles then i'm going to have
a coaster put on my shoulder so when i
go to a bar i can say you wanna drink on
me
and then i'm just gonna be like a
monster and for halloween i'm gonna
dress up like a normal human being